thirty days with me would change your
life your relationship status and your
income trust me my babes in the front
right here jog it over here jog it over
your hand up stand up stand up come on
[Music]
someone that I'm always fascinated by
one of my favorite actors Michael B
Jordan he had been kind of like on the
skinnier side and it seems like starting
with Fantastic Four and now for Cretu
he's just like in completely insane
condition I reached out to Corey Callie
ate Michael B Jordans trainer
I'm celebrity trainer Corey Calle while
4 and a half years ago I met Michael B
Jordan when we started off Mike had no
muscles throughout the years we've
trained through different movies coming
up on three two this time I was able to
take his body to a whole nother level
I'm the guy that you go to when you need
to get yourself in shape really fast by
the end of this we'll see if maybe I
look like someone who could possibly be
in the ring and a Creed movie
hey don't Corey what up bro Chris to
meet you same enforcer
so today is day 1 of 30 let me see your
music it's not bad now what I could do
with this in 30 days I can almost
guarantee you still haven't asked by the
time we finish is you ready to get
started very excited let's do it let's
do a bro so over the next 30 days the
workout we're gonna do is kind of gonna
match our signals with what I did on
Crete started off with early
conditioning running its traditional
what you lifting when it comes to
dumbbell squat rack shoulder presses
different things like that I think your
biggest challenge is gonna be staying
consistent fight through the pain
fighting through the hurt fighting BB I
don't feel like it
you know those I don't feel like it
maybe tomorrow what you're gonna have 30
days so you don't have tomorrow tell the
truth this hurts as opposed to alright
so we're gonna do that all over again
you ready right here let's go come on if
you can be consistent throughout the
whole process your body will start
changing as far as Michael this is was a
everyday thing for him and you have to
dedicate discipline yourself to what you
are trying to do to achieve that goal
there's no shortcuts so we're done with
day one you didn't die yet I don't know
what happens when I go home I mind if I
was to grade this I would give him a
seat I see because he can do better
although from here you heard it I feel
like I'm just getting kills right now
this first week has been brutal the meal
prep has proven to be the most difficult
after the first week and I think for a
person with a 9 to 5 who is not like an
actor with a chef and you're not like
being paid to dedicate your life to this
it is certainly more challenging what
people don't understand is you can be a
boxer you could be anything you want but
to give the look that you want that real
transformation comes with a diet a lot
of a high protein I play with the
carbohydrates depending on when he
needed it and I kept the fats at a very
balanced out level throughout the day
water was very importantly maybe a
gallon has two gallons of water a day
one thing I was not prepared for about
this was just how exhausting the whole
gallon of water thing
we're just trying to create the look of
a boxer and aesthetically where do you
think we're at I think we're at a good
spot of course we just have 30 days so I
had to get the best idea that I can I
see already change if you look at from
the first time we interviewed and right
now you can see how your arms are
starting to come off
how to Rhonda seen your shoulders come
your vascularity is coming through as
you can see now I'm taught to see he's
getting abs right now so you see the
changes coming into muscles so that lets
you know that with me you can change it
30 days so for these these last two
weeks what are we gonna change workout
wise going to up the pace a little bit
we're gonna add more cardiovascular so
that we're gonna add more super sets and
tricep training like that because we
want to get the muscles going when you
get the blood pumping so in order to get
you ripped down I gotta get you moving a
little bit more faster so the weight
will come down story time I had gone to
a concert and you know I just wanted to
let loose a little bit and I had like
three I had four plus vodkas point being
my decision-making became a little bit
impaired right concert ends I get back
and I'm looking through the food
delivery app and what pops up Taco Bell
eventually at around 3:00 I get a
notification on my phone it's from door
- and they say that the order is
canceled my initial thought McDonald is
still open there 24/7 I could just go
there but then I thought about it and
I'm like okay maybe I should take this
as a sign yes I slipped up a little it's
no reason to just toss away the entire
diet and throw everything off track I'll
see you I'll see you when this is all
over Taco Bell don't you worry I just
went for a run was just kind of like
extra cardio for the day but I think
that's a good sign because I usually
have zero desire to do anything really
on a Saturday night I just feel like I'm
starting to kind of get into a good
groove it's just such a limited amount
of time so when you put Corey's name on
it just have this fear of like ending it
and being kind of in the same place I
started so I'm trying to make sure
there's some there's some type of
results here
so we're finally at our last training
session he has to make sure that we give
everything today I don't want to see him
tired I heard something like that
I want to see him going all the way
through it giving everything that he can
and basically keeping up with me nobody
started off he's a little water is the
song thirty days later
but I put together really works it just
takes time and dedication and you
protects to make it half day one workout
I almost died in like five minutes
right right right I didn't know if I was
gonna make it how do you think the day
30 performance but that fast pace how do
you think that compared I think today
you was able to see him be different
than you're gonna see you on the first
day I'm the workout was great we did go
out a very faster tempo higher pace I
tried to make him quit that was my goal
always making you quit to get the best
knife you as you can see if you look at
his body from the first day his pectoral
muscles abdominals shoulders upper chest
biceps everything is starting to form
basically what this says is that no
matter who you are a movie star or not
if you take the time consistency and
discipline and do it if you get the same
type of body I think your 30 days we
were able to do more than what I do with
some active
[Music]
you